he hacked the Pentagon and NASA when he
was 15 the damage they caused is
estimated at $1.7 million but who was he
really Jonathan Joseph James born on
December the 12th 1983 in Pine Crest
Florida on June the 29th 1999 he gained
access to 13 computers on the Marshall
space flight center NASA there Jonathan
James found the sources of the programs
used to control the whole International
Space Station he hacked a server of the
US Department of defense and downloaded
more than 3,300 emails from Pentagon
employees mailboxes Jonathan was
arrested on the 26th of January 200000
if Jonathan James had been an adult he
would have faced 10 years in prison but
he got 6 months house arrest 8 years
later 25-year-old Jonathan James was
found dead in his home with a gunshot
wound to the Head his death is still
shrouded in mystery and the true details
and circumstances are unknown to
[Music]
anyone